hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to
Jurassic Park what can you say about it
it's a classic story of sign screwing
with nature sort of the monster movie
meets family adventure Jurassic Park
introduced groundbreaking effects
heart-stopping action scenes and
continues to be Steven Spielberg's
highest-grossing film so as you can
imagine there was a lot of hype for
Steven Spielberg to do another movie hey
you know what mr. Spielberg before I
even knew what you had you packed it you
packaged it you swept on the plastic
lunchbox and now you're selling this
you're selling it well lost world
talk about a letdown see this will be
sore like a mix between Congo and the
biggest whiners at PETA the characters
are idiots the story's absurd the effect
aren't as good as the first movie so
what's the point in seeing it for you
none for me I'm a glutton for fucking
punishment so let us sink our teeth into
the lost world so we start off on a
different Island we're a family on their
yacht is spending their vacation rich
people in a monster movie I'm sure this
is gonna end fine for them what little
girl is this any real child would take a
look at that little dream monster and go
[Music]
it certainly is
and now for comedic ly over-the-top
scream in three two what seriously what
woman especially seeing her daughter
getting eaten would take the time to
raise her arms in the air and throw them
down you do that while telling a joke
mr. crack and then we cut to this was
the movie trying to make us think she
was screaming at Jeff Goldblum granted I
would scream at that too but that's kind
of a confused joke that's that's famous
there so we see our main character Ian
Malcolm oh fuck it let's just call him
Jeff Goldblum because we all know that's
who he's really playing he dropped by
the house of John Hammond played again
by Richard Attenborough as we see some
other familiar faces the two little kids
from the first movie it's so great to
see you
what a order they're a very brief cameo
we do
we're then approached by men in suits
who they must be the villains they're
led by Hammonds nephew named Peter who
is not happy as Malcolm was the only one
of the survivors who broke the
non-disclosure agreement and told
everybody about the island wait a minute
so dr. grant never told anybody dr.
Sadler Hammond the kids what's wrong
with these people there's fucking
dinosaurs loose the only person who
tells anybody about is the one nut ball
who obviously nobody's gonna believe you
signed a nondisclosure agreement before
he went to the island that expressed
fish too bad you can't go seeing
anything you saw that agreement yeah I
didn't you lied you questioned the facts
surrounding the deaths of three people
three wow that's great a fucking
scientists arcade cap why didn't nobody
believed only said there were dinosaurs
again that's that's famous speaking of
which it looks like there's another
Island with Dinosaurs on it that Hammond
wants Goldblum and a team of people to
observe this was called site B a site
they had to leave because of a hurricane
and so all the animals have been roaming
free for the past four years what
happened to the first island you might
ask it disappeared into the void like
the rest of the plat holes you'll see in
this bill okay so there's another Island
with Dinosaurs no fences this time and
you want to send people in there very
few people on the ground okay okay if
I'm gonna continue on with this review I
have got to get my Jeff Goldblum
impression down
so to help out with that well right now
Jeff Goldblum impression is
[Music]
the odds and and plus in in every every
sentence the secret is to uh never
complete complete eight seconds without
going off or but but but there's there's
more consumer to doing Jeff Stowell blow
is to put the antenna me broth words
words words Mensa that's secret here so
when you want to say a statement
statement that is up not the secret to
doing a go
yes so him until Gollum that his nephew
wants to exploit site B and bring the
dinosaurs to a park in America and of
course he wants Gollum to go in and
preserve the animals public opinion is
the one thing that I can use to preserve
it but in order to rally that kind of
support I need a complete photo record
of those animals alive and in their
natural habitat and seeing how you are
almost eaten by happen then I figure
you'd be the perfect person to protect
them
total them of course says no but him and
threatens that if he doesn't he'll never
see his girlfriend again is in contact
Sarah valiant illogical behavior study
is a brand new field and Sarah Harding
is on that front yet you sent my
girlfriend to this island alone oh hell
do you go on the trip to an abandoned
island filled with dinosaurs and not
tell your boyfriend I guess like most
women she just want to get as far away
from Jeff Goldblum as possible it's not
a research expedition anymore it's a
rescue operation and it's leaving right
now
[Music]
oh did I put on the soundtrack to the
first Jurassic Park again so ghulam goes
and gets his team together including vin
fawn yeah we also come across chili
Goldblum's only daughter wait a minute
one daughter getting kids me oh oh hell
yeah three I love kids I I can't read
her right good for you it turns out
Kelly is sad because big shock Jeff
Goldblum's not that hot of bother you
know sweetie I know we've had some hard
going but I feel like in the last couple
years we've really kind of started to
work things out hasn't been better yeah
but I want you to crack on me a little
bit ground me or something send me my
room you never do any of that stuff what
kid is this yeah because if there's
anything children complain the most
about it's not getting punished enough
you got your your gymnastics competition
you've been training for that for months
you like to have kids be just don't want
to be with them to you
hey I'm not the one who dumped you here
and split for parish that don't take it
out on me nice parenting there Goldblum
want to bring up her aborted brother
while you're at it so the team makes it
to the island in search of Sarah only to
find that her bag is left behind Wow
even these dreams for his possibly dead
girlfriend sound disinterested uh-huh
it's like one of this various olives got
in the way of that line
Sarah ah they've been come across a
couple of stegosauruses and Marvel and
water and yet don't get used to this
whole enchanting thing by the way
there's very little Bay in this movie
and eventually they do come across Sarah
played by Julianne Moore wait stay there
be quiet Q just ask the impossible from
Jeff Goldblum stay there and be quiet it
can't be done
[Music]
we see she finds an ET knockoff and
decides she wants to pet it but her
parents see her and charge in an angry
rage this of course was all to the
thrilling anti clinics but it turns out
there's bigger things to worry about
like cold blooms daughter sneaking on
board the trip Kelly what are you doing
hey don't go out there it's not safe
same here you guys should definitely go
but I'm gonna stay I love you I just
don't need you right now
I'll tell you what you need a good
antipsychotic you know in the first
Jurassic Park they at least tried to set
up some character an interesting
conversation here it just feels like
filler until the fucking t-rex gets
there in fact let's play a game a little
game I like to call try to be invested
just listen to this conversation and
obviously act like you give a crap
seriously just trying to be interested
so listen when you're out in the field
nothing we can do something I'll be in
their presence needs to be 100%
antiseptic if we fucking I just see the
lawyer getting eaten again
that's awesome can I just watch that for
two hours but they hear a noise in the
distance a horrible terrible sound what
could it possibly be mad
yes man what's an amide your hamster
okay okay we know the drill gypsy who
these guys are
oh it's that Peter jerk again and this
time he's accompanied by another Peter
Pete Postlethwaite
and his killer cheekbones as they try to
hunt down some dinosaurs for their zoo
in America really you hired people to
hunt dinosaurs who don't even know the
names of the dinosaurs why don't you go
hunting with a person who doesn't even
know the name of the animal you're
hunting oh it's big got antlers it's
it's got these really big hooves oh I am
yeah so our heroes look over the horror
of what they're seeing and they let it
all sink in
[Music]
what have we become
after all we're going after innocent
creatures like this or this or even
adorable vis so the two Peters come
across a baby Tyrannosaurus and trappin
in order to capture the mother
so on a scale of one to ten how douchey
is that this is incredibly douchey it's
just like Hitler she no doubt about it
but luckily Vince Vaughn is loading up
and ready for action
Hammond told me these people might show
up I thought we'd be finished by the
time they got started but in case they
weren't he did send a backup plan
back-up plan me he never uses a weapon
in this movie but to be fair Vince
Vaughn is no stranger to tough
situations what a hot older woman made
you feel her cans stop crying like a
little girl what'd you do with them
you play the motorboat you've
motorboating son of a bitch you old
sailor you so like freakin idiots they
let all the dinosaurs out of their cages
yeah wouldn't you know it they run amok
thank God they released all those
animals no absolutely no human beings
will be horribly injured at all by the
way what dinosaur could literally throw
a car into a tree what is this the Babe
Ruth asaurus
[Music]
and if you think that was stupid of our
heroes take a gander at this they find
the baby t-rex and bring him to the
trailer are you guys fucking morons
won't you just like eat me all over you
uh-huh there it is there's the fracture
right above the epiphysis Oh dad I gotta
get out of here please
I wanna get out yes listen to the girl
she's the only one who knows what she's
talking about
in fact let's start taking bets about
who's gonna die in this movie you got
annoying blabbermouth of Jeff Goldblum
idiot scientist Julianne Moore not such
a badass badass Vince Vaughn or punchy
doughy guy who's only had eight lines
tell me folks who do you think is gonna
die let me emphasize that this is who
you think is gonna die not who you wish
was going to die there you go
so Copeland gets his daughter to safety
but they hear the t-rex in the distance
so he tries to call them to let them
know the t-rex is getting closer we have
no idea what his metabolism is will kill
him with killer so put him into
respiratory arrest Nick I need your
hands you know what they deserve to die
no really
Little Rock Gogol said it himself nature
is selecting them for extinction as far
as I'm concerned our t-rex child come
right back but you never keep your word
oh you got a point well later bitch
so of course Gollum arrives just in time
to recreate the t-rex raining scene for
the first movie
don't move their eye sights based on
who's expendable
[Music]
is this a hunting vegan well Jesus
Christ we have a renting scientist who
can't count an idiot scientist who
kidnaps baby t-rexes and a dumbass
hunter who lets dangerous beasts go is
the black girl the only one who has a
brain in this movie so then look the
baby t-rex out and everything seems to
be ok but when - no it t-rex's our
vengeful now as they come back and try
to shove a trailer off the cliff they
try to break the windows open to get out
but they just won't budge thus the
trailer is knocked over the side and
hanging by a thread do something do
something
[Music]
no you meet Sarah minute a second ago
they couldn't get the glass open now the
slightest bit of pressure is gonna bust
it those trailers as reliable as a BP
pipe
the needs to grab her in time as doughy
guy comes in to save the day okay so is
one chief somehow badges to pull up two
trailers yeah you figure that one out
when guess who returns now tell me why
the hell do these two come back did they
just want to make sure they were still
hanging there maybe instead of just
leaving them on a clip they were like oh
yeah we're dinosaurs
let's fucking eat something oh hey is
that mommy is she angry you might still
have a chance if she's not very angry so
the guy gets eaten and watch this both
trailers fall right through them not
damaging one fucking hair on their heads
I haven't been impressed with such
incredible Lux at the pipe seen from
twister some people have all the
contrived conveniences don't they that's
that's faster so the hunters find our
heroes and managed to pull them out I
just like to point out it was mean
terrible man who helped you out that
incident while those harmless dinosaurs
you were trying to protect ate your
doughy guy and kicked you off a cliff
I'm moving the baby Rex into our camp we
may have changed the adults receive
territory know what why they persist in
destroying the trailers and I feel they
have to defend this entire area again
we'd like to thank our main heroes for
attending to the baby and dooming all
people on the island so they journey to
the only control tower where they can
possibly make contact friends but they
have so you're gonna be in the remake of
psycho war yeah me too fucking agent on
the bright side maybe we can tell we mhm
may see not to be an atheist Jurassic
Park movies so if they take a break one
of the hunters played by Peter Stormare
gets attacked by the comeuppance Oris
because he attacked them earlier the
other hunters forget about him almost as
fast as the audience does but later that
evening they hear something going bump
in the night
it turns out it's the t-rex because he
smells the blood on Julianne Moore's
jacket interesting they said before his
eyesight's based on movement but now he
operates by smell kind of weird you
would think he would smell dr. grant and
the girl in the first movie seeing how
his nose is right in front of them but
hey their ancestors a mosquito I'm sure
their genes got fucked up somewhere so
of course everyone starts fleeing in
fear and the t-rex tries to catch up
with it again kind of weird in the first
movie the t-rex was fast enough to catch
up with the chief in this movie he's
struggling to keep up with a large crowd
of people if I did dr. Hammond in the
first film say we plucked the t-rex to
32 miles an hour slowing it down oh well
I guess this one has a disadvantage from
the other film see how this one was not
kept in captivity has been hunting in
the wild for four years I guess that
would slow any dinosaur down again
mosquitos 15x must be crazy that's
that's oh my god a snake is there
anything worse so while the t-rex is
eating the snake ofoh Jeff Goldblum
comes in and helps everybody escape only
to be attacked by Big Shot poor
dinosaurs
okay how many lines does Jeff Goldblum
whisper in this movie movies very angry
hang on okay so while the rest of them
try to outrun the Raptors Vince Vaughn
gets away and makes it to the top trying
to radio for help
[Music]
meanwhile the Raptors attack and gold
ones getting tries to get away from
there no don't you remember they can
open doors and that too he manages to
hide in the building with the other two
but they get trapped on the second floor
Kelly no Kelly don't it's too cliche
needed to contrive yes folks she's using
her flips and kicks from her gymnastics
class to save the day
[Music]
yeah you think that's bad enough but
listen to this I love the fact that the
Raptor actually turns when she says hey
you I mean Jesus he actually fell for it
I thought these things were supposed to
be super intelligent and the move that
gets the drop on them is a you what else
do you think these morons would fall for
oh no no I can't believe I fell for that
I can figure out how to open a door but
not when I'm being half oh god my
bathroom time I'm a bad bad Raptor they
finally get away when the chopper that
Ben phone called finally arrived but
Papa wait still wants to take care of
that darn t-rex
[Applause]
that's one souvenir they won't be taken
with him you stole their bullets people
your asshole these are the people that
helped you out of the cliff and told you
where the radio tower is and you're
honestly going to take away their only
means of defending themselves Jesus
what'd you ever do is wave your finger
at how people are gonna get killed and
you're constantly getting people killed
you are both heroes all of you you
deserve to be shocked
damn it's fun I guess in the long run it
doesn't matter because they still
capture the t-rex anyway and bring him
to San Diego the ship crashes into the
docks as it seems the t-rex got out of
his cage ate the crew and somehow locked
himself back in the cage where's the
crew all over the place look at us don't
you love it how the t-rex ripped a guy
from his hand and yet somehow didn't
damage any other part of the room
consider it animal isn't he well of
course some dumbass presses the button
and accidentally what's the t-rex go
allowing the monster to run amok all
throughout San Diego now you're John
Hammond
that's right now you're John haven't I
didn't even know we were supposed to
hate him by this point but do I hate him
now
so the t-rex Rome is the neighbourhood
it searches for water yes nothing you
should see Suzi next door
Oh looky the boomer makes a cameo in
this movie yes but we'll get you another
boomer
so go bloom in more go to find the baby
t-rex as a means to lure the father back
to the boat hey you think you're doing
taking a kid you want to stop us
shoes no they just let him drive away of
course because you know it's not like
it's their job to stop them or anything
and we see the t-rex ripping the city in
new
oh wait a minute king lear starring
Arnold Schwarzenegger why the hell
aren't I watching that movie you'll go
back and start again film I want to see
Arnold
so they lure the t-rex back with a baby
he eats that Peter bad guy and they
finally steal him back in the boat and
thus we get our last minute moral from
the evil John Hammond oh I hate him so
much I hate him so much
knowing the music syndicating we like it
now these creatures require our absence
to survive and if we could only step
aside just in nature
[Music]
this was dahm dahm dahm dahm this film
was so fucking dum dum da da dum
gah what a terrible follow-up to a
kick-ass movie I'm not gonna act like
the first film was perfect but it was a
basic fun survival flick this this just
seems phoned in the characters are
forgettable well they're not incredibly
stupid the story is unbelievably forced
and the whole animal rights thing really
backfires when the people trying to
promote it are constantly making things
worse there's no sense of wonder no
sense of adventure it's just set up
scenes for the dinosaurs to walk in and
destroy that's it it's a bad sequel
plain and simple the only good thing to
come out of this is maybe someone will
possibly get the idea to film King Lear
with Arnold Schwarzenegger and when the
highlight of a movie is another movie
that doesn't exist that's a bad sign I'm
the Nostalgia Critic I remember it so
you don't have to
[Music]
you
now uh there were supposed to be a
dinosaurs dinosaurs in this dinosaur
review right hello hello yes that's
that's good